this video is sponsored by athletic
greens which means we will have an ad
from them somewhere in the middle hello
everyone I'm Alana and welcome to my
channel where today as a bunch of you
have been requesting of me I'm sorry
that I went to this a video game came
out it's been time consuming
um I am finally catching up on a bunch
of trailers that I had missed we are
going to start with Avatar the way of
water which is one that I am very
excited to watch like literally as a
trailer sometimes there are trailers
that you get excited to see two of these
I'm very excited about which is um
Avatar the way of water and John Wick
but for very different reasons the
reason I'm so excited about watching the
Avatar trailer which I promise I'll get
to very shortly is that I know that
whatever I'm about to watch even if I
didn't love the first avatar I saw it
three times in cinemas I contributed to
the creation of the second one
um because it's just going to be
visually unique and I think one thing
that James Cameron does really
consistently that's super impressive is
um is push
this idea of this mature 3D that not a
lot of other people are pursuing really
at all it's a visual Feast even for the
next two minutes outside of the movie
itself so
um like this first shot's already
beautiful let me make sure that we're
watching in full 1080p all right let's
do it this is Avatar the way of water
the latest trailer came out two days ago
[Music]
unbelievable already
Jesus Christ why do you come to us
I just want to keep my family safe
dude
that water has to be real
treat them as our brothers and sisters
teach them our ways
if you want to live here
under what is hard right
it's hard
you can't be serious is this this can't
be there's no way this is this has to be
live action
thank you no
like that's a person in a mocap suit
actually in water surely
surely
Just Breathe
breathe
I mean that that is actual water
beautiful shot
yes that's all they see
I see
experience the motion picture event is a
great way to sell this whoa that's
gorgeous
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Avatar the way of water beautiful
experience it in 3D Peters
December 16th don't care about the story
at all okay I don't care
um that trailer is what I expected on
crack right it's beautiful it is
visually stunning it is time to talk
about ag-1 by athletic greens which is a
nutritious drink that'll really help you
simplify your health routine at least it
has for me and I love it ag1 has 75
different ingredients including vitamins
minerals superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens it's your daily multivitamin
and multi-mineral pre and probiotic
immunity support and more and yes it
provides your daily green splend too
there are a lot of greens powders on the
market but what ag-1 does is a little
bit more important than your regular
greens powder greens powders do provide
critical phytonutrients but these
nutrients don't Empower gut health by
delivering the phytonutrient blend along
with a multivitamin probiotics
adaptogens more ag1 creates an
environment where the gut can Thrive so
the body can Thrive too and again you're
getting all of this in something that
you just put some powder and you put
some water and you shake it up and then
you drink it every day it's super simple
it tastes great I think the two things
that I find the most helpful uh recovery
ag-1 has a bunch of magnesium in it
which is something that a lot of people
are lacking in so it helps with
performance and recovery for me I'm
always tired and I work too much ag1 is
really really helpful for energy it has
energy supporting ingredients such as a
natural form of B12 never synthetic
biodin bioavailable folate and magnesium
so go to athletic green
slash a lot of peers to get started on
your order athletic greens is going to
give my community a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin D3 plus K2
and 5 free travel packs with your first
purchase I would love a breakdown of
which of these things are live action
and which aren't because like it what
was it it was the bubbles coming from
somebody's face when they came
underwater they just broke my brain
I think it was right after this
you have to ride
let's do it that
that's just got to be a person I don't I
don't know um I'm sorry that I'm not
informed it's probably gonna frustrate
people in the comments but
wow uh water is really hard
I know that working in video games to be
fact and
this is crazy impressive
um
damn and I know that um what's really
interesting is James Cameron
said that uh this movie I'm gonna miss
quite in probably here but this movie
was like a terrible business venture
um I believe it has to make two billion
dollars at the box office to return that
is an expensive film like
to not lose money you have you're
betting on yourself making two billion
dollars
my dude
that's so nuts this person said which we
can't really verify but they said I was
one of the first creature designers who
worked on this film worked on the Flying
Fish slash crocodile creatures the whale
creatures and more with a bunch of other
insanely talented people and I just
wanted to say thank you to all of you
the fans some of us who worked on the
movies do take the time to read the
comments on trailers seeing the trivia
truly overwhelming positive response
from you all so far has made the years
of work that have gone into these films
worth it for all of us truly thank you
I'll see you in the theater in December
could be true who knows we need more
trailers like this it doesn't give away
everything about its plot it doesn't try
to be actiony or flashy it just lets you
be fascinated I mean I don't disagree
this is a great trailer like I said I
feel like I was always going to enjoy
the trailer but I don't think we need
more trailers like this because it's
selling the best part of this film right
like what it is doing is going hey we
know that this part of this film is
awesome here you go and that's what
every other trailer does it's just that
they often have to focus on plot because
that's the selling point or they focus
on action or flashiness because that's
the selling point
um this is fascinating because it's
visually interesting it doesn't have the
other strong pillars to advertise to you
necessarily I could be completely wrong
they could have nailed the story this
time around and again just my opinion of
course
um fantastic trailer great job great job
hey James Cameron uh who knew
uh okay next up I'm gonna do probably
the one I'm the most excited about in
this lineup that I have for you all
today which is John Wick chapter four
John Wick on the other hand well I do
think is visually
um also very interesting and obviously
really well choreographed and
beautifully shot I love the law
I'm really into John Wick law like I
just really enjoy it I like
um the way that the city's set up and
and what the hotel means in the currency
and I just I think that the World
building
um which I believe uh they've done kind
of piece by piece it wasn't all planned
out to begin with which is super
complicated
um is really exciting to me so it's very
video gaming in a way so super excited
about this one so this is the trailer
for John Wick chapter four it's coming
out in 2023.
same device
saying hello
you think your wife can hear you
no
a white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
I'm going to die
maybe not well everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
a new day is Dawning
new ideas the wolves
no management we've known each other
since
[Music]
who is this
it's a way out
interesting I don't sit at the table who
your family does please pray for me
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried
I'm going to need a gun
delivery my
God is just so unique
[Music]
okay what the heck all right
the table will honor its word
we will have your freedom
under the old laws only one can have
chills I love this so you have to meet
at sunrise
for results and execution beautiful
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
[Music]
it's I want you to find your peace but
the good death
only comes after Goodbye
Oh my God
whoa you and I left a good life behind a
long time ago my friend
very cool again so videogamy
so that ruled I love this
um for very different reasons I do think
it's a little bit funny that they're
like hey you just have to kill this one
guy meet at this time I mean I love that
as a premise I think that's what gave me
chills is I think that that's so cool
the idea of that in the way that's built
up
um everything to do with the table
obviously that LOL I'd love to see a
John Wick book I wonder if one exists
yet
um but it is a little bit funny that
they're like if you just kill this one
dude
if you can't you'll be executed like
they haven't tried to execute him before
not necessarily an execution I suppose
um but what makes anyone think that they
could kill him unless he's like just
gonna respect the table and let them
murder him
it's not really a threat to John Wick
you know okay yeah try and kill me like
it's not really worked out in the past
this is a really good point Donnie Yen's
59 keanu's 58 these guys are still
moving so well very very true they are
they're incredible what they do
I think the best part of these movies is
what Gianni says I'm gonna need a gun
and no matter what Morpheus is or
anybody is always smiling it's very true
definitely much respect for Keanu lots
of love for him in the comments uh I
love Donny as well that that is awesome
I also legit had goosebumps watching
this trailer yeah
no one ever thought when the original
came out that this character would jump
into popular culture that this world
would Intrigue people and make them
interested in knowing more about it it
was so well written so well directed but
most importantly Keanu made his this
movie franchise what it is today
I guess people disagree on it being well
written I don't know dude like I said um
I love the law like I just think it's
awesome I think all of the law in this
trailer sign me up dude I want to learn
more about it I I just I it's totally
disagree sorry agree with this comment
the intricacies in the story are in the
details of the world and the rules of
the hotel 100 what motivates people to
break or follow the rules yeah it's it's
definitely deeper than just Mindless
shooting
um even if maybe the characters aren't
that complex it's it's a really complex
structure it's not that different to A
Game of Thrones it I mean it is pretty
different but it it um it cites the same
enthusiasm and it has the same appeal to
me in a way of like the politics of this
universe that I'm unfamiliar with I
think are really exciting dope trailer
love it I and again I've liked every
single one of them
um I hope this lives up to the record
that they've already established because
they are killing it
um next up
I wanted to do Marvel Studios Ant-Man
and there was quantum Mania which I
don't remember this February 17 2023
um these are three very different
trailers I imagine and the last one
they're gonna watch is even more
different probably which is um the whale
um it's an a24 movie that maybe less
people have heard of but I'm such a fan
of their movies that I just wanted to
show that one as well so let's do
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at x-con
how are you an Avenger the tone is
already so different like everybody
people tell me the same thing it's
almost shot like a spider amen
like a TV show that might help that
that's why we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal she's soaked out to the quantum
Realm
turn it off
now
it's actually just every woman in
that man a good looking seat
[Music]
hmm interesting how much they do tell us
about this from the jump
wow okay there's gonna be like a whole
volume green screen
I love that
my secret Universe beneath ours I feel
like the tone of this is probably going
to be sort of what are you so afraid of
Guardians
there's something I never told you
this place it's a bit so it's just a lot
of CG um what do you think isn't as
appealing as it is for some reason I
don't know why the Sci-Fi I don't know
maybe it looks very similar to others
[Music]
it's cool
and give you more time
you help me
so
What's it gonna be
Ant-Man
it's cool
hey very creative could go really
anywhere
um I don't love this trailer as much
um I think like
maybe just coming off after those other
two which are incredible doesn't hit
quite as hard but um I love what they've
done with the character Scott lining uh
I love this cost in general actually um
I mean Paul Rudd he's amazing will take
him forever he's fantastic
um I think I just have this thing where
my brain bounces off of the Sci-Fi CG
these days and I wonder if it's just
that I've seen too much again clearly I
was forgiving of Avatar because I feel
like that's because it was water and uh
creatures and and life forms but I know
that's just me I'm sure that's an
unpopular opinion it's just uh
saturated in my head it doesn't mean
there's anything wrong with it
um but also yeah I mean they really did
set up a lot of the premise of that
movie in this trailer
well simultaneously because it because
of the the quantum Mania because of this
Quantum realm it really could go
anywhere they could get super creative
with it um
I don't know just not as excited about
this one personally I think
they just have a struggle of a lot of it
feeling really samey to me at this point
I just burnt out on the MCU
um
I was actually expecting this trailer to
be funnier for whatever reason I was
expecting to see more humor in it I
think
let's see what the comments say how
wrong am I
the guy who said Thank You Spider-Man
would have probably been Stanley if he
was still here
that's true that's
that's sad to think about
sorry about whoever made the trailer
song as a genius combining yellow brick
road by Elton John with the Loki theme
was brilliant composing oh I didn't even
notice that but that is smart
yeah yeah watch the trailer of a dozen
time get chills every time honestly hype
to see Kang in action so also definitely
excited about Kang that is very very
cool
I love how the MCU Blends in amazing
songs to add to the cinematography yeah
I don't disagree with that
it's using the mainstream songs makes
sense
anyone else fight it so wholesome that
Cassie gets to do what she always wanted
team up with a dad and be a partner so I
I already knew that that was sort of
revealed before this trailer came out
right I feel like I already knew that
people seem to like Kang and like the
music
I don't know they seem to like it a fair
bit
it's it looks good just uh yeah maybe
not for me then that's okay um all right
final one here we're gonna watch the
trailer for the whale
this is the full movie
1080
yeah let's do it
expecting something very different again
here
[Music]
yeah sorry um I know about this movie
because Brandon Fraser's in it I imagine
that's that's the case for a few people
[Music]
very dark it's like 24 it makes sense
[Music]
[Music]
people are incapable of not caring
[Music]
people are amazing
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
um definitely tonally looks very
Aronofsky
um
beautiful cinematography that is some
beautiful cinematography I love how
short this trailer is I love the
dialogue that they've chosen to use and
I think I I'm probably not alone in just
having a lot of fondness for Brendan
Fraser these days and just like wanting
I think it's just really nice to see him
get compliments um and sort of come back
in a way he's making me cry with just
that one shot of how he's acting with
his eyes pure talent missed him totally
agree with that yeah it is really cool
that he's really really selling the
movie that's awesome it's so nice to see
I gotta scroll past all these bots of
just women with boobs out
stop make it stop no not that I have a
problem with it YouTube just doesn't
like it they don't like it when I show
it they don't care when it's they're in
their own comments I guess definitely a
lot of love for Brendan Fraser huh yeah
totally agree
this makes me see Cinema and acting
differently to be honest it's not just a
story that Brendan and Darren wanted to
tell it's a genuine reminder of how
great people are
we could use more of that in film too or
in everything I guess Brandon is so
amazing and honestly a gem within the
film industry for his personality as
much as his acting skills and all the
people that are supporting him not just
because they want to see the film but
because they rightfully care about him
as a person a beautiful strong person
they're so amazing too I hope no one
ever gets this film because it says a
lot about people
yeah I hope he's he's aware of this I
hope he's aware of of how
happy people are to um
to see him return it's it's got to feel
super nice
um
and we will leave it there
like I said some very different trailers
just wanted to catch up people kept
asking me to I'm sorry that I missed
John Wick in the first place
um and all the others I guess I'm so
just so behind on stuff but uh I hope
you enjoyed this video thank you guys
for hanging out I'll see you next time
bye